i'm frank von hippel I'm a nuclear  physicist I've been at Princeton since  nineteen seventy-four working on nuclear  weapons issue and I see this as a great  opportunity with the election of  President Trump and this the responsive  citizen uprising that this may be an  opportunity move our agenda poured on  nuclear to some of them I was part of  the last wave in the early 1980s when we  rose against the early Reagan  administration and helped end the Cold  War and the nuclear arms race and  reduced the number nuclear weapons we  have but there's still too many York  last year too dangerously march on  warnings we still have a one man who can  who can order their use all these issues  have to be dealt with and I welcome I  would I would welcome that the citizen  uprising the president rumpus has  stimulated to develop a nuclear  dimension as well to try to move our  nuclear gender forward toward vehicle  nuclear disarmament  [Music]  [Music]